[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en donde
hacemos un resumen de las noticias más
destacadas relacionadas con la pandemia
de kobe 19 en nuestro continente a
continuación les presento algunos de los
temas que vamos a tratar en este
programa
vamos a retomar el tema de la variante
delta y delta + o delta plus esta
variante ya está presente en cerca de 14
países de la región según lo confirma la
ope s lo que representa un gran desafío
para la región de américa latina en
donde la vacunación avanza lentamente y
los casos de contagio no se den veremos
que otras variantes son de preocupación
para la organización mundial de la salud
hablaremos de perú este país recibió una
donación de dosis de vacunas por parte
de eeuu todo un incentivo para el plan
de vacunación que será fortalecido
también veremos qué medidas ha tomado el
gobierno peruano para hacer frente a la
amenaza de las variantes delta y la
variante lambda que precisamente es una
variante originaria de los andes
peruanos daremos un vistazo a la
situación general de este país
suramericano se los vamos a contar en
minutos y haremos lo mismo con costa
rica con cindy regidor nuestra
corresponsal en san josé la capital
costarricense veremos en detalle cómo
está la situación en ese país
centroamericano líder
en los avances en cuanto al plan de
inmunización nacional en donde incluso
ya fue autorizada la vacunación para las
mujeres embarazadas y en donde pese a la
situación tres cantones o regiones allí
en costa rica no registran casos de
contagio noticias alentadoras
ya veremos entonces en detalle
bueno pues ya como les estaba diciendo
vamos a comenzar hablando del tema de la
variante delta vamos a conversar con el
doctor daniel lópez acuña epidemiólogo
ex director de la acción sanitaria de la
organización mundial de la salud con él
vamos a profundizar en este tema que se
encuentra en la ciudad de gijón en
españa gracias doctor para acompañarnos
a esta hora aquí en kobe 19 la semana en
américa y comienzo por preguntarle
entonces esta variante del tal ya está
presente en 14 países de américa latina
es una región en donde la vacunación ya
lo hemos visto avanza lentamente a que
nos estamos enfrentando con esta
variante
la variante delta debe preocuparnos
porque es una variante que tiene una
doble mutación que la hace más
contagiosa y que la hace más proclive a
eludir la eficacia de las vacunas
es una variante que hasta ahora sabemos
es 40 a 60 por ciento más contagiosa que
otras variantes anteriores es una
variante que además amenaza por ejemplo
en europa con convertirse en la variante
dominante en agosto de acuerdo a lo que
establece el centro europeo de control
de enfermedades con un 70% de los casos
al principio de agosto y un 90% de los
casos al final del mes de agosto y es
una variante que además genera infección
contagio en personas que no tienen la
pauta completa de vacunación quienes
sólo tienen una dosis de vacuna entonces
tenemos una situación de una variante
que ya hizo estragos en la india que ya
hizo estragos en nepal que ha dominado
la escena de contagios y ha incrementado
la incidencia y la des
escalada en el reino unido- que domina
en rusia que empieza a avanzar en
portugal y que seguramente tendrá una
gran presencia amenazante en la mayor
parte de los países de europa no es solo
en europa que se extiende está en
américa del norte empieza a extenderse
en
latina en américa latina especialmente
en américa del sur tenemos el gran
problema de que convergen con la
variante gamma o variante brasileña p
uno de manaos que también es altamente
contagiosa y bueno está por encima de
todo esto además el surgimiento de una
estirpe o su variante de la variante
verdad que la llamada variante delta
plus o delta más que es una combinación
de la variante delta con elementos la
variante sudafricana de nuevo con alta
proclividad a producir una escape o
elusión de las vacunas o de la eficacia
las vacunas con respecto a la enfermedad
doctor lópez de acuerdo con información
que hay disponible es sobre este tema
leo textualmente y hace falta
información de la variante delta para
poder determinar si se pueden
neutralizar por anticuerpos generados
por las vacunas disponibles o por la
infección por medio de otra variante de
coronavirus qué opciones tenemos y
específicamente entonces qué significa
esta parte que le acabo de leer
a qué nos estamos enfrentando entonces
bueno vamos vamos a ver existe existe la
necesidad de todos los países de hacer
más vigilancia epidemiológica y
secuenciación genómica de las variantes
la delta entre ellos para saber cuál es
su verdadero grado de penetración esa es
una primera realidad segundo necesitamos
reforzar nuestra evidencia información
sobre la efectividad con relación a las
vacunas el informe que emitió de riesgo
de la variante delta el centro europeo
de control de enfermedades que digamos
es el ámbito de colaboración
epidemiológica de todos los países de la
unión europea señala que cuando hay una
sola dosis de las distintas vacunas es
todavía importante el riesgo de
infección y de contagio tenemos que
tener una evaluación más pormenorizada
de la efectividad total con doble dosis
de las vacunas con respecto a la
variante delta pero mientras tanto lo
que tenemos que hacer es contener su
avance
y reducir el riesgo de interacciones
sociales que propician el contagio con
estas o con otras variantes doctor lópez
la vacuna de johnson y johnson
esta farmacéutica desarrolló la vacuna
ginseng ha demostrado ser aparentemente
muy efectiva a la hora de evitar el
contagio de casos de la variante delta
que se habla en la comunidad médica o en
la comunidad científica sobre este tema
el último informe que la organización
mundial de la salud emitió hace un par
de días señala que todas las vacunas
aprobadas tienen efectividad contra la
variante delta lo que pasa es que varía
esa efectividad esa efectividad puede
ser de un 30% si sólo se ha puesto una
dosis y no se tiene la pauta completa y
variará cómo varía la efectividad con
respecto a otras a otras variantes
tenemos vacunas que están basadas en el
procedimiento de la rm al mensajero que
son eficaces en un 90% o más
vacunas con muestras étnica o jensen y
tienen un 70 a 80 por ciento de eficacia
pero en cualquier caso siguen
funcionando hasta el momento con
relación a las variantes pero no sabemos
qué variantes van a surgir y cuanto
estas variantes van a lograr eludir la
eficacia de las vacunas doctor esta
variante delta plus usted nos daba
algunos detalles sobre ella es de mucha
más fácil transmisión también es
considerada por la oms como de
preocupación qué diferencia tiene
entonces con el resto de las variantes y
qué es lo que la caracteriza y a qué le
debemos temer a la variante delta plus
porque ya la delta está haciendo
estragos en el mundo entero delta plus
pues tal vez no nos da un nombre muy
positivo
si como le mencionaban las mutaciones
que ha experimentado el virus y que
generan la estirpe delta plus que es
como una sub variante de la variante de
venta y hacen que combine elementos de
lo que hemos visto en la variante
sudafricana y lo que vemos en la
variante delta y esto la hace más
contagiosa a avanzar a un ritmo más
rápido producir cuadros con mayor
severidad y tener mas proclividad a que
la vacuna no funcione plenamente
especialmente cuando el ciclo es
incompleto es decir estamos
enfrentándonos a variantes que son más y
más difíciles de manejar y de contender
y mientras mas proliferen la transmisión
y no logremos avanzar lo suficiente la
vacunación mundialmente mas
expresión de variantes vamos a tener
porque el virus va a tener más capacidad
de mutar doctor en ese orden de ideas
con un virus que está mutando
rápidamente que está cambiando
constantemente es necesario hacer y
aplicó este término que usted también lo
ha mencionado vigilancia vigilancia
genómica es decir hacerle el rastreo al
virus de cómo se está comportando y cómo
se está modificando pero según los
organismos internacionales y también
muchos especialistas aquí en el
continente americano han dicho que
américa latina está rezagada en este
seguimiento a las variantes que riesgo
implica entonces para una región como
américa latina en donde hay tantas
diferencias sociales en donde hay una
gran diferencia en la vacunación entre
un país y otro y en donde la vacunación
en líneas generales está avanzando muy
lentamente los países van a llegar a una
inmunidad en muchos meses más hacia
adelante más más lento que muchos otros
países si lo comparamos con eeuu o
canadá con algunos países europeos
tal vez ya estamos ante nuevas variantes
en nuestro continente que todavía no
hemos detectado
sí yo creo que son varios los riesgos
que se enfrentan en américa latina'
uno de ellos es la baja capacidad en
términos logísticos estructurales de
llevar a cabo esta vigilancia genómica
de las distintas variantes mientras no
hagamos eso no tenemos una idea clara de
que tan penetrantes han sido o no en
nuestras sociedades y eso nos puede
llevar a no a subestimar las acciones
que se lleven a cabo para controlar la
pandemia segundo yo creo que estamos
ante una expresión muy clara
a través de los datos de incidencia que
vemos colombia tiene una incidencia muy
alta de más de 800 varios países de
américa latina están en el orden de los
600 700 son incidencias 67 veces mayores
que las que estamos viendo en la mayor
parte de los países europeos hoy y esto
es producto de dos cosas la lentitud con
la que avanza la vacunación y la
inequidad de la distribución y acceso a
las vacunas que está golpeando
particularmente a américa latina pero
también
reticencia de muchas autoridades
sanitarias y políticas de américa
latina' de tomar medidas más
contundentes para frenar la transmisión
no podemos apostar lo todo a la
vacunación hay incidencias altas en
muchos países de américa latina que
requieren la acción más contundente de
salud pública y de medidas no
farmacológicas o restrictivas mientras
se avance en la vacunación claro su
mensaje doctor daniel lópez muchas
gracias por estar con nosotros en el
programa gracias por atendernos en esta
consulta muchísimas gracias vamos
entonces a pasar a explicarles cuáles
son las variantes que están activas en
este momento en el mundo o por lo menos
las que la organización mundial de la
salud clasifica en diferentes categorías
por ejemplo de preocupación o de interés
debido al comportamiento que tiene cada
una de ellas en cuanto a la vacunación a
las vacunas o mejor las variantes desde
lo que estamos hablando las variantes de
preocupación la ms decidió nombrar las
de acuerdo al alfabeto griego para
evitar que entonces el origen del sitio
donde había sido descubierta
donde había sido determinada por primera
vez generará un estigma para los
ciudadanos de ese país entonces
comenzamos con alfa que es la letra a
que fue detectada por primera vez en el
reino unido- en el norte de europa beta
fue identificada en sudáfrica y sigue
siendo una variante predominante en esta
región del continente africano gamma es
una de las variantes latinoamericanas
fue identificada en el 2020 en brasil la
famosa variante delta y sus sub
variantes identificadas como delta plus
fueron determinadas en india también en
el continente asiático quiero también
destacar les la categoría de variantes
de interés estas son la variante zeta
que también fue identificada por primera
vez en brasil es otra de las
latinoamericanas y la variante lambda o
variante de los andes' que fue
identificada en perú son las variantes
que han surgido en la región de américa
latina y que son las que son
predominantes en nuestro continente por
lo menos en la parte de sur américa
y vamos a ver ahora algunas de las
cifras de contagio y de fallecidos en
diferentes países del continente para
este cierre de semana así es como están
las cosas vamos a enfocarnos en la parte
media de nuestro continente vamos a
comenzar entonces en belice este país
centroamericano reporta más de 13 mil
300 casos y 329 personas han fallecido
allí en el caribe jamaica allí
contabilizan 50 mil 166 casos o tal vez
un poco más y mil 80 personas han
fallecido hasta el momento no muy lejos
de allí haití con una compleja situación
política y también con una compleja
situación sanitaria reportan más de
18.500 casos y al menos 436 personas han
fallecido de acuerdo al conteo oficial
su vecina república dominicana
contabiliza para el cierre de esta
semana más de 326 mil casos y más de 3
mil 800 personas han fallecido seguimos
en el caribe cuba también cierra esta
semana reportando más de 193.000 casos y
un poco más de 1.300 muertos récord
que cuba es el único país que ha
desarrollado una vacuna propia
y como enfrenta chile entonces la
amenaza de la variante delta la pregunta
tiene lugar cuando hay ya dos casos
confirmados en ese país suramericano
chile también extendió el cierre de las
fronteras una frontera con argentina que
es sumamente extensa y sumamente porosa
vamos a ver entonces cómo están las
cosas en este país saludamos a patricia
luna en la ciudad de santiago para
conocer más detalles
hola patricia gracias por estar con
nosotros en el programa como siempre un
gusto y que dicen allí las autoridades
en santiago sobre la amenaza de la
variante delta allí ya fue confirmado un
segundo caso según los reportes
oficiales que dicen
hola santiago cómo estás la llegada de
la variante delta preocupa mucho a las
autoridades en chile el ministro de
interior reconocía que se ha tenido que
postergar la implementación de una serie
de reformas al plan paso a paso que iba
a suponer una nueva serie de aperturas
en un momento en que se produce un
descenso sostenido en el número de casos
esto mientras continúa la polémica en el
país por la introducción de la variante
delta y cómo se produjo fue a través de
una ciudadana chilena de 43 años
residente en eeuu que acudía al país en
relación al fallecimiento de su padre
aunque en un principio se informó que no
había acudido al fin al funeral se
reconoció que la paciente había mentido
y que se acudió al funeral de su padre
también a un mercado a una peluquería y
a una cafetería sin embargo las
autoridades del maule de la región del
maule no han podido confirmar por el
momento la existencia de más casos
vinculados a esta variante aunque sí se
ha iniciado una investigación por parte
de la fiscalía que tratará de establecer
la responsabilidad en delitos de salud
pública hay un segundo caso de variante
del está que se introdujo en el país por
un joven chileno que está en este
momento aislado en una residencia
sanitaria
patricia allí en chile extendieron el
cierre de las fronteras son muy pocos
los vuelos internacionales que arriban a
este país pero esto tiene grandes
complicaciones para las personas que
viven cerca la frontera con argentina es
una frontera muy porosa ya lo decía yo y
algunas poblaciones dependen del
intercambio comercial con poblados que
están en el lado argentino ha afectado
la vida de las personas y también
extendieron allí el estado de excepción
que implican entonces estas medidas para
los chilenos
así es santiago a la llegada de la
variante delta ha hecho que se refuerce
el cierre de fronteras el aeropuerto
arturo benítez de santiago permanecerá
cerrado hasta el 14 de julio por lo
menos se ha incrementado también la
cantidad de test antígenos y de pcr que
se realizan si realizan un pcr positivo
es enviado completamente directamente a
secuenciar para establecer qué tipo de
variante se está introduciendo en el
país en el momento solo pueden entrar a
chile en los chilenos y también los
extranjeros residentes en cuanto a los
controles fronterizos por tierra solo se
está permitiendo la llegada de camiones
que introducen suministros esenciales al
país también se ha extendido el estado
de catástrofe hasta el próximo 30 de
septiembre que es el que permite al
gobierno establecer medidas extremas
como pueden ser el cierre de fronteras
el establecimiento de cuarentenas y
también el muy polémico toque de queda
chile está en un toque de queda continuo
desde marzo de 2020 es él uno de los más
largos del mundo y muchas personas
cuestionan cuál es la validez de este
toque de queda en este punto patricia
chile es uno de los países líderes en la
región en cuanto a la vacunación
está la situación allí en cuanto a los
casos a los fallecidos hagamos entonces
un panorama general del país
pues así es de las 52 comunas de la
región metropolitana que hace unas
semanas estaban completamente en
cuarentena sólo tres permanecerán en
cuarentena se ha iniciado en el proceso
de des confinamiento en las últimas
semanas que se ha producido un descenso
sostenido en el número de casos en las
últimas 24 horas se informa donde los
2600 2700 una cifra muy alejada de las
9000 que se registraron hace varias
semanas y este descenso se ha producido
en todas las regiones en un 25% según
las cifras ofrecidas por las autoridades
lo que no ha descendido tanto aunque sí
levemente ha sido el número de personas
que se encuentran en las unidades de
cuidados intensivos los hospitales
siguen estando saturados y también es
bastante alto el número de personas
fallecidas recordemos que hasta el
momento más de un millón y medio de
personas han sido contagiadas en chile
por la enfermedad desde el inicio de la
pandemia y que hay más de 32.000
fallecidos con pcr positivo esto en un
momento en que en un 83 por ciento de la
población objetivo de 15.200.000 sobre
los 19 millones de chilenos ya ha
recibido una primera dosis de la vacuna
y un 70 por ciento de la población
objetivo ha recibido las dos dosis de la
vacuna y ha completado
de inoculación lo que explicaría estas
cifras más bajas que podrían verse
amenazadas por la llegada de la variante
delta mucho más contagiosa y ante la
cual la vacuna mayoritaria utilizada en
chile- la vacuna china sinovac no ha
demostrado por el momento su eficacia
patricia muchas gracias por este
completo reporte desde la ciudad de
santiago vamos a cruzar la cordillera de
los andes hablamos ahora de argentina la
ministra de salud de ese país carla
vizzotti dio unas palabras a unos medios
internacionales en donde explicó la
actual situación hospitalaria por la que
está atravesando ese país que pese a la
saturación del sistema el sistema de
salud argentino todavía no ha colapsado
pero sí hay un gran temor en cuanto a la
llegada de la variante delta esto fue lo
que dijo la ministra argentina ha hecho
un esfuerzo enorme en fortalecer el
sistema de salud se ha duplicado a nivel
global y algunos lugares están inclusive
triplicado el número de camas el número
de respiradores pero sobre todo tiene un
un equipo de salud personal de salud que
da una respuesta inmensa
que realmente no solamente se ha
capacitado aprendido sino que también ha
buscado formas de que nuestro sistema de
salud pueda seguir dando respuestas
inclusive en la segunda ola que ha
superado y por mucho la primera y eso es
algo que todavía no hemos valorado
suficiente en argentina y seguramente lo
valoraremos con la perspectiva del
tiempo nosotros siempre analizamos esta
situación y argentinas tiene un número
de casos importantes un número de
fallecidos importantes es un país muy
extenso que tiene grandes aglomerados
urbanos que tiene una situación social y
económica que no es de ahora que no le
permite a la población no salir a
trabajar hemos tenido algunas
dificultades en los acuerdos políticos
para que todos los arcos políticos
también puedan estimular los cuidados y
eso sin duda también ha tenido impacto y
de ninguna manera ha sido el único
factor
así que desde este punto de vista es
esperable en función de la extensión del
país los aglomerados urbanos y también
argentinas de un registro que es
sensible del número de casos y del
número de muertes que también con el
tiempo y la perspectiva se va a poder
comparar con análisis más técnicos de lo
que es exceso de mortalidad en países
que por ahí todavía no tienen un
registro del número de fallecidos por
millón de habitantes por hobbit pero
conoce haga ese análisis se pueda ver
que en realidad fueron más lo cual a
nosotros no nos soluciona ningún
problema pero con esas comparaciones
siempre es importante analizarlo la
entrevista completa con la ministra de
salud de argentina carla vizzotti la
pueden ver en la programación de france
24 y por supuesto en todas las redes
sociales del canal principalmente en
france 24 punto com avanzamos con otros
temas brevemente les cuento otras
noticias destacadas de esta semana
seguimos en argentina este país
restringió aún más sus fronteras sólo
permitirá la entrada de 600 personas por
día al país se suma la prohibición
también del turismo internacional que
está completamente vetado desde
pasado mes de diciembre la medida fue
tomada para retrasar la circulación de
la variante delta no muy lejos de allí
bolivia comenzó a vacunar a los mayores
de 18 años esta medida entra en vigor a
partir del primero de julio y en los dos
próximos meses bolivia espera recibir
cerca de 8 millones de dosis de la
vacuna china scinopharm y por último nos
vamos a esta ecuador también allí
iniciarán la vacunación masiva de
ciudadanos entre los 16 y los 48 años
marcando así la prioridad que le ha dado
el gobierno del presidente lazo a un
rápido avance de la vacunación en esa
nación suramericana
de mostrador un vistazo al avance de la
vacunación en otros países y regiones
pero les traigo cifras globales para que
evidencien ustedes como estaba avanzando
la inoculación en todo el planeta veamos
entonces las cifras al día de hoy
solamente el 23.7 por ciento de la
población mundial ha recibido al menos
una dosis de alguna de las vacunas que
está disponible en el mercado 3.13
billones de dosis ya han sido
suministradas en todo el planeta pero el
promedio es solamente de 40.7 millones
de dosis suministradas diariamente en
todo el planeta solamente el 1% de los
habitantes de los países de bajos
ingresos han recibido al menos una dosis
de alguna de las vacunas
y en perú hay presencia de diferentes
variantes ya lo decíamos una de ellas la
variante lambda es originaria de este
país se le llama también la variante
andina y por otra parte este país tuvo
buenas noticias a lo largo de esta
semana recibió un generoso lote de
vacunas que fue donado por eeuu y con
esto esperan reforzar el plan de
vacunación vamos entonces a preguntarle
más detalles a francisco zacarías
nuestro corresponsal en la ciudad de
lima francisco que está allí en lima
gracias por acompañarnos hoy en el
programa y ya están en perú es el lote
de vacunas de facer que fue enviado
precisamente por eeuu como será entonces
la distribución de estas dosis y de
cuántas dosis estamos hablando
santiago son 2 millones de dosis de
vacunas pzifer y 160 ultra congeladoras
que el gobierno de joe biden ha donado
al perú para apoyar a este país en su
lucha contra la pandemia alcoy 19 el
presidente francisco sagasti recibió el
primer lote de más de un millón de dosis
y se espera que en los próximos días
llegue el resto de las vacunas las
autoridades peruanas ven con entusiasmo
la donación de eeuu y aseguran que ésta
acelerará el proceso de vacunación de
las personas mayores de 50 años mientras
tanto el gobierno peruano continúa
ejecutando su plan nacional de
vacunación y espera que 8 millones de
ciudadanos que son alrededor del 25% de
la población estén inmunizados con las 2
dosis contra el kobe y 19 a fines de
julio cuando culmine la gestión de
francisco sagasti
francisco allí en la capital de lima le
pregunto en la capital de perú le
pregunto cómo ha sido el tratamiento que
le ha dado el gobierno de perú a las
variantes delta y lambda haciendo esta
variante la última que mencionó la
variante andina que fue originaria en
este país que dicen allá de algún caso
reportado ya
un estudio de 1714 muestras realizado
por el instituto nacional de salud en
todo el país revela que la variable
lambda registra un 70 y 1.6 por ciento
de casos los científicos peruanos nos
afirman que si bien predomina la
variable lambda hay que temerle más a la
variable del está considerada como la
más peligrosa las autoridades hasta el
momento han reportado tres casos de la
variable delta en la región sureña de
arequipa y uno en lima en las últimas
horas las autoridades de salud de este
país aislaron en la capital a 19
personas relacionadas con el caso
registrado en esta ciudad todos se
encuentran con cerco sanitario en sus
domicilios como medidas de prevención
para evitar la propagación del virus el
gobierno ha pedido a la población
conservar las medidas de bioseguridad
uso de mascarilla distanciamiento social
y lavado de manos el ministerio de salud
ha admitido que es probable que en un
futuro relativamente cercano
la variable delta del corona virus pase
a predominar en el perú
francisco hagamos balance de la
situación en este país suramericano en
cuanto a contagios vacunados personas
que han fallecido cuál es el panorama
gene
según estadísticas de la
superintendencia nacional de salud el
número de ingresos de pacientes de
coronavirus a las unidades de cuidados
intensivos ha ido descendiendo pero la
demanda continúa siendo alta por otro
lado las autoridades revelan que debido
a que los adultos mayores ya están
vacunados las personas de 30 y 59 años
son las que se están contagiando y son
éstas las que están requiriendo mayor
demanda de oxígeno en los hospitales
hasta el momento la sala situacional del
coi 19 en este país reporta además de 2
millones de contagiados y más de 192.000
fallecidos
diversos expertos advierten que hay
grandes posibilidades de que se presente
una nueva tercera ola de contagios y
calculan que ésta comenzaría a finales
de julio o principios de agosto las
marchas de protesta por la lentitud de
los resultados de las elecciones en perú
podrían generar el incremento de nuevos
casos
francisco muchas gracias por este
reporte desde la ciudad de lima y el mes
de junio fue para colombia el más
crítico de lo que va de la pandemia
durante ese mes el país suramericano
reportó récords de contagios de casos
activos y también de fallecidos las
autoridades siguen apostándole a una
lenta vacunación a nivel nacional con la
esperanza que pueda avanzar ante la
pandemia
una esperanza en medio del tercer
repunte de casos confirmados que dejó 17
mil muertes reportadas solo en junio el
país recibió este jueves 2,5 millones de
vacunas de la farmacéutica janssen
donadas por el gobierno de eeuu y lo que
esperamos es que en este mes de julio
que empieza lleguemos a 25 millones de
vacunados y sin lugar a dudas marc estos
2.5 millones de vacunas van a ser
fundamentales en ese propósito
las donaciones llegan en medio de un
escenario de convulsión política que ha
marcado a esta nación sudamericana en
los últimos meses con sólo el 13 por
ciento de la población completamente
inmunizada los colombianos viven el peor
momento registrado durante la pandemia
que ha cobrado más de 106 mil vidas en
medio de una reactivación económica que
incluye la reapertura oficial de bares y
negocios la ocupación de las unidades de
cuidados intensivos en las principales
ciudades en colombia registra más del 90
por ciento en medio de nuevas variantes
que representan mayor riesgo de contagio
para las personas que aún no reciben la
vacuna la crisis generada por el cob y
en la economía colombiana no permite
volver a una cuarentena estricta y hay
que abrir porque hacia destrozado la
economía nuevo separar los económicos
que es por pelo socioeconómico y no para
el individuo no sólo la organización
panamericana de la salud advirtió que la
situación está empeorando en la región y
que el fin de la pandemia es posible en
un futuro lejano
y ahora nos vamos a esta costa rica hay
novedades en ese país centroamericano
entre ellas la alta ocupación
hospitalaria allí en san jose está cindy
regidor nuestra corresponsal en el costa
rica- cindy gracias por acompañarnos hoy
en el programa y hablemos de la variante
delta que han dicho las autoridades
costarricenses que medidas están
pensando en tomar dado el caso que se
empiecen a presentar casos allí en costa
rica
hola santiago el inevitable ingreso de
la variante delta ha causado
preocupación en las autoridades
costarricenses por ser más transmisible
y por su capacidad de agravar a quienes
se contagian de ella todavía no se
registra oficialmente la presencia de
esa mutación en el país pero el ministro
de salud daniel salas llamó a la
población a no bajar la guardia y
mantener las medidas para evitar los
contagios principalmente con el uso de
la mascarilla el lavado de manos y
evitar aglomeraciones el ministro
también advirtió a la población de que
las vacunas que se aplican en costa rica
si brindan protección incluso contra las
nuevas variantes del virus aunque esta
protección puede variar y baja ante las
nuevas mutaciones siempre son efectivas
para evitar la enfermedad grave
cindy hablemos de esa leve disminución
de casos de contagio que se están
registrando incluso ya tres cantones
costarricenses han reportado que no
tienen casos de kobe 19 y también
comenzó la vacunación para las mujeres
embarazadas
los casos si han disminuido pero de
forma leve en las últimas dos semanas
por ejemplo la reducción de casos
positivos de coronavirus fue de 3% las
autoridades explican que al ser una
disminución lenta el país se mantendrá
al menos una semana más en alerta
naranja esto implica algunas
restricciones de movilidad vehicular
clases suspendidas y regulaciones para
establecimientos de atención al público
las muertes también han bajado en
promedio cada día fallecen 17 personas
por causas relacionadas a la cob y 19 la
mayoría en el rango de edades de 50 años
a más en total el país registra 4 mil
600 muertes desde el inicio de la
pandemia sin digamos el balance general
para el cierre como están los números de
casos personas fallecidas y también
punto importante la ocupación
hospitalaria
costa rica- avanza con su campaña de
vacunación pero a la vez lidia todavía
con una alta ocupación en hospitales y
en salones de cuidados intensivos en un
país de 5 millones de habitantes el 32%
ya recibió una dosis de vacuna contra la
cob y 19 es decir un millón 600 mil
personas y un 16% cuenta con una dosis
una buena noticia es que las personas
embarazadas podrán vacunarse porque la
comisión de vacunación lo autorizó esta
semana que se les aplique el fármaco
facer que es el que tiene más estudios
sobre la seguridad de su aplicación en
esta población en general el ritmo de la
vacunación varía entre semanas
principalmente debido a que también
varía la cantidad de dosis que el país
recibe de las casas farmacéuticas a las
que les compro las dosis también es
destacable que existen considerables
diferencias entre los ritmos de
vacunación de las distintas provincias
algunas áreas de salud vacuna más rápido
según su población la distribución de
grupos prioritarios la disponibilidad de
las dosis y los recursos a su alcance la
tasa de vacunación de costa rica es de
47 tres una que actual
es mayor a la tasa mundial que es de 38
07 muchas gracias cindy por este
completo reporte desde la ciudad de san
josé capital de costa rica pasamos ahora
a nuestra sección en redes veamos otras
noticias destacadas de la semana aquí en
kobe 19 la semana en américa la
farmacéutica johnson y johnson anunció
resultados prometedores contra las
variantes que han surgido del hobby 19
las muestras han dado una respuesta
satisfactoria de esta vacuna contra la
variante delta que sigue extendiéndose a
nivel mundial y genera mucha
preocupación por la rápida propagación
que tiene brasil suspende el contrato de
vacuna contra el kobe 19 con firma india
en medio de acusaciones de
irregularidades pese a la necesidad que
tiene este país de adquirir vacunas el
país suramericano suspendió un acuerdo
de compra de 20 millones de dosis de la
vacuna kovác sin que es fabricada en
india así lo anunció el ministerio de
salud de brasil luego de que surgieran
dudas sobre el aumento de los precios de
manera repentina y para el cierre este
titular
s pide a occidente conocer y reconocer
mejor las vacunas chinas contra el kobe
19 pese a que las vacunas de la oms s a
las que les dé la autorización para el
uso de emergencia deben ser reconocidas
por los países a nivel mundial es decir
que esta medida obliga entonces a los
países de occidente a aceptar las dos
vacunas fabricadas en china
aparentemente menos efectivas eso sí
ante los ojos de europa y de eeuu pero
que son ampliamente usadas en buena
parte de américa latina y también del
continente asiático
es todo por el momento en este resumen
de kobe 19 de la semana en américa sigan
cuidándose de el coronavirus la
emergencia sigue latente nos vemos la
próxima semana con más noticias
relacionadas con la pandemia de kobe 19
hasta pronto
[Música]